oprah winfreys arianna huffington tut es
mit ryan und angelina jolie ebenfalls
und auch steve jobs soll darauf
geschworen haben
achtsam meditieren der trend der
achtsamkeit oder die mannes ist aus den
usa längst in die schweiz gelangt auch
am diesjährigen wef in davos wurde
täglich meditiert und zwar unter der
leitung von jon kabat zinn der die
achtsamkeit praxis im westen berühmt
gemacht habt ich freue mich sehr dass er
heute bei mir im studio ist herzlich
willkommen schon cover ziehen
ich freue mich hier zu sein aber sie
kommen direkt vom flughafen haben sie
heute schon meditiert das ist eine etwas
ungewöhnliche frage wenn sie sich
wirklich auf die anwendung von
meditation einlassen
merken sie sehr schnell dass es nicht
einfach darum geht sich zeit
freizuschaufeln um klassisch zu
meditieren
mir geht es um ihr verhältnis zur
entfaltung ihres lebens dadurch wird mit
der zeit das leben selber zur meditation
meditation ist nicht einfach im
schneidersitz pose da sitzen wie eine
statue im britischen museum machen sie
das überhaupt nicht mehr
doch natürlich mache ich das aber für
mich ist dieser art meditation nicht
echter als im flugzeug zu sitzen und mir
bewusst zu sein dass ich ins studio
fahren für dieses interview mit ihnen
sogar dieses interview ist für mich eine
form von meditation
da bin ich gespannt wie das gespräch
verlaufen wird wenn man sich fragt was
achtsamkeit eigentlich ist mein tun es
dann ist es interessanter sie in ihrem
buch eine geschichte eigentlich erzählen
die gleichzeitig in einem cartoon
wiedergegeben wird von garn wilson sie
beschreiben nämlich eigentlich diesen
karten hier
wir sehen hier zwei mönche und der alte
mann ist ein junger mensch nichts
passiert als nächstes das ist es ist das
wirklich schon
nämlich das ist es sondern dies mit
anderen worten dieser moment was auch
immer sich entfaltet ist die aktualität
des gelebten lebens die eigene erfahrung
wie sich das leben entfaltet
die frage ist also sind sie bereits
dafür oder erwarten sie ein besonderes
erlebnis eine meditative erfahrung ohne
zu merken dass eben genau dieser moment
unglaublich spezielles tatsache dass ich
meinen mund und meine zunge bewegen kann
und sie verstehen was ich sage meine
augen funktionieren meine ohren
funktionieren ihre augen und ihre ohren
funktionieren
das ist doch ein wunder und wir
übersehen das gerne sagt im wesentlichen
dass jeder einzelne moment unglaublich
einmalig ist keiner ist besser als der
andere
es geht vielmehr um die frage wie wir
mit den erfreulichen und den
unerfreulichen momenten umgehen und den
anderen die gerne übersehen werden sie
auf 10g nicht im moment sondern in der
zukunft
ja es gibt zwei orte um abzutauchen wenn
sie so wollen die vergangenheit in der
erinnerung
all die gedanken an die vergangenheit
warum etwas so gewesen ist um nicht
anders und meist auch wer daran schuld
ist und dann die zukunft um die man sich
sorgt und wenn man plant das ist
vollkommen in ordnung so arbeitet unser
gehirn ohne vorstellungsvermögen für die
zukunft wären wir nicht menschlich und
wenn wir uns nicht an die vergangenheit
erinnern könnten würden wir nicht
funktionieren
aber wenn sie von vergangenheit und
zukunft komplett absorbiert sind dann
wird die gegenwart der einzige moment
den wir live erleben ziemlich eng
das hat auswirkungen auf unsere
lebensqualität die gesundheit usw
diese arbeit daran im moment zu sein
diese meinten es bewegung das ist ein
enormer boom im moment wenn man bei
amazon des stichwort mein schönes
eintippt dann erhält man über 40.000
treffer es gibt bücher es gibt kurse es
gibt cds dvds
und sehr viel davon bezieht sich auf
ihre arbeit wann haben sie schon
kapazitaet ali siert welchen riesen
trennt sie da losgetreten haben
als erstes möchte ich festhalten dass es
viele verschiedene strömungen und leute
gibt die zum blühen der achtsamkeit
bewegungen in der breiten öffentlichkeit
beitragen
nicht nur aber das ist geschieht war
schon vor vielen jahren meine absicht
als sich die meint von espace stress
reduction klinik im medical center der
universität von massachusetts gründete
die hoffnung war meditation und im
speziellen achtsame meditation als
allgemeine behandlungsmethode zu
etablieren
für amerikaner die unter stress unter
chronischen krankheiten und so weiter
leiden und dass dies sich dann wie ein
flächenbrand ausbreiten könnte es gibt
so viel leiden auf der welt und immer
suchen wir nach lösungen außerhalb von
uns selber damit alles besser wird oder
wir alles loswerden
achtsamkeit hingegen ist ein weg sich
mit der eigenen erfahrung anzufreunden
mit dem guten in dem schlechten und im
hässlichen und trug damit umzugehen so
dass man in einem gewissen sinn das auf
und ab eines lebens steuern kann
mit vollem bewusstsein und mit einem
gewissen maß an gelassenheit und
mitgefühl für sich selber surfen person
wenn ich mir ihren weg vorstellen sich
ja erst mal interessant sie haben
molekularbiologie studiert und dann
wurden sie während des studiums
irgendwie sagen wir mal infiziert er vom
interesse an meditation wie kam es dazu
ich besuchte er 1965 eine vorlesung von
einem gewissen philipp kablow der
reporter bei den nürnberger
kriegsverbrecherprozessen gewesen war
danach ging er in ein kloster in
hokkaido japan eiskalt im winter um dort
zen meditation zu lernen
er sagte unter anderem dass das sein
leben vollkommen verändert
er habe an geschwüren und anderen stress
bedingten problemen gelitten und nach
sechs monaten meditation in einem
eiskalten kloster seien diese probleme
alle weg gewiesen
ich war damals 21 22 jährigen als ich
ihn hörte wurde mir bewusst dass ich
mein leben lang genau das gesucht hatte
nämlich mein wissenschaftliches
verständnis vom körper geologie und
gesundheit zu verbinden mit einer art
künstlerischen verständnis für die
schönheit des lebens und seinen vielen
unterschiedlichen ausdrucksformen von da
an begann ich zu meditieren und 265 und
es war so bedeutsam für nicht dass ich
nie mehr aufgehört hat reduction
programm gegründet mbs er das auch in
der schweiz wegen fuß gefasst hat man
kann kurse dazu besuchen
ich stelle mir vor dass das ein langer
weg war und wahrscheinlich auch viele
widerstände ich nehme nicht daran dass
alle ärzte sie mit offenen armen
empfangen haben gesagt haben
super idee machen wir jetzt es hat
wahrscheinlich sehr viel
überzeugungsarbeit gebraucht ihrerseits
direkt shui sind eigentlich gab es keine
großen hindernisse oder
herausforderungen
ich glaube ärzte wissen irgendwie dass
sie ihren patienten nur bis zu einem
gewissen punkt helfen können und dass es
viel besser wäre wenn die leute bei der
behandlung zum erreichen der gesundheit
und eines besseren wohlbefinden smit
wirken würden es gibt viele gute und
wirksame möglichkeiten die man seine
biologie seine physiologie selber
beeinflussen kann
und da ich meine ausbildung zum
molekularbiologen im labor eines
nobelpreisträgers absolviert hatte ging
man davon aus dass ich wisse was ich tue
so ließ man mich machen und dann sind
die patienten zu den ärzten zurück
gegangen und haben dinge gesagt wie
dieses achtwöchige mb s r programm hat
mir in acht wochen mehr geholfen als sie
in acht jahren für meine gesundheit
erreicht haben die ärzte realisierten
dass es wirklich wertvoll ist im rahmen
der medizinischen versorgung ein angebot
zu haben dass die leute befähigt sich
ein leben lang selber an eurer
gesundheit und an ihrem wohlbefinden zu
beteiligen sich auch weiterhin meinen
dann live institut dem auch dalai lama
im vorstand angehört und in diesem
institut geht es auch darum eigentlich
diese diesem zusammenhang zwischen
buddhismus meditation und der modernen
wissenschaft herzustellen
es gab verschiedene studien in denen man
beispielsweise den nicht den
buddhistischen mönch war theorie gar
verkabelt hat man hat ihn in einen
kernspintomographen gelegt wir sehen
hier im bild wer sich da in den
demokraten reinlegt und er also man hat
dann hier untersucht dann hat man
gesehen dass ich tatsächlich das hirn
während der meditation
anders verhält sie haben schon gesagt
sie sind molekularbiologe
naturwissenschaftler ist es für sie
wichtig dass man sozusagen physikalisch
dass man das irgendwie
naturwissenschaftlich erklären kann dass
er sich zeigt auch wirklich im hirn
ich glaube das weckt tatsächlich das
interesse der breiten öffentlichkeit an
der achtsamkeit und an der meditation
ganz allgemein
es gibt laufend immer mehr
wissenschaftliche untersuchungen und sie
werden immer überzeugen wird
was sie hier sehen mit dem meditierenden
materie ist ein beleg für die
neuroplastizität mit anderen worten das
gehirn ist ein äußerst plastisches organ
das durch erlebnisse geformt wird nicht
nur seine aktivität wird beeinflusst
sondern es verändert auch seine struck
als folge von repetitiven handlungen
meditation ist eine sehr repetitive
tätigkeit und manche leute mögen zuerst
denken dass es langweilig ist weil man
ständig das gleiche wiederholt aber nach
einer weile realisiert man dass nichts
interessanter ist als die aktuelle
moment sobald die wissenschaft anfing
sich damit zu befassen
ich begann damit 1979 wurde es sehr
schwierig zu behaupten dass meditation
nichts bringe doch nun hatten wir nicht
mehr bloß die anekdotischen nachweise
von zahlreichen patienten mit vielen
unterschiedlichen chronischen diagnosen
sondern auch die wissenschaftlichen
objektiveren resultate sie zeigten dass
meditation die physiologie sowie die
architektur und struktur ihres gehirns
wirklich verändert heute wissen wir auch
dank der wissenschaft die epigenetik
heißt dass meditation die genexpression
in den chromosomen verändert und
hunderte wenn nicht tausende
verschiedene gene steuert die
verantwortlich sind für krebs für
entzündungsreaktionen erstmal ein
bisschen mysteriös
können sie das naturwissenschaftler
erklären die sich epigenetische
veränderungen ergeben können durch
meditation
niemand weiß wie meditation dieser
gehört aber es ist nicht die meditation
allein ich bin sicher dass viele
verschiedene faktoren mitspielen die
ernährung wie viel sie schlafen oder wie
tief ihre beziehungen zu anderen
menschen sind wir wissen dass die
biologie der gattung mensch sehr komplex
und sehr vernetzt
wenn sie zum beispiel ruhe und
gelassenheit pflegen hat das
auswirkungen darauf welche
chromosomen exprimiert werden wir
verstehen den mechanismus dafür nicht
genau aber die wissen bereits genug um
zu erkennen dass dies wichtig ist und
man vielmehr forschen
ich machte in den späten 90er jahren
eine studie die zeigte dass wenn man
leute mit zur iss
die hautkrankheit bei der man sieht was
mit dem haus passiert wenn man die leute
in eine uv licht box setzt verbessert
sich ihr zustand
man nennt das foto therapie bei der für
haftet wenn sie aber in wir licht box
mit ihren erfolg die heilung viermal so
schnell ihre haut verbessert sich
viermal schneller als bei jenen die bloß
eine lichttherapie erhalten
irgendwie kann also der geist den körper
auf die ebene der genexpression
beeinflussen
darum geht es in der epigenetik solche
dinge dann gibt es auf die interessanten
daten über das altern an den enden von
jedem unserer chromosomen sind diese
strukturen die repetitiven dna sequenzen
die sogenannten telomere und die
telomere scheinen länger zu werden wenn
man meditiert steht man unter stress
wenn sie kürzer und kürzer und wenn man
die telomere verliert hören die zellen
auf sich zu teilen was eine art
biologisches zeichen von altern ist
sie haben wohin gesagt aus sie
angefangen haben wussten sie schon dass
es den leuten besser geht es viele von
erfolgen berichtet haben bezüglich ihrer
heilung aber auch einfach von mir
wohlergehen jetzt zeigt die wissenschaft
mehr und mehr auch in anderen bereichen
eben welche resultate machte das auch
stolz ich bin glücklich ich würde nicht
sagen dass ich stolz darauf bin ich sehe
es nicht als eine art individuelles
verdient worüber ich sehr froh bin
es gibt so viel leid auf der welt
viel davon entsteht durch unser eigenes
bewusstsein unseren lebensstil die art
und weise wie wir miteinander umgehen
wenn wir nun mehr und mehr überzeugenden
nachweise dafür entwickeln dass wir für
uns selber und für die gesellschaft in
der wir leben verantwortung übernehmen
können und so leid und schaden
minimieren und wohlbefinden und
gesundheit verbessern weisheit und
mitgefühl
dann wird es irgendwie zwingend dass wir
uns vermehrt in diese richtung bewegen
ich glaube wir sind an einem punkt wo
die beweise deutlich vielleicht sogar
erdrückend sind
es geht um eine fähigkeit die zu uns als
menschen gehört würden wir sie
kultivieren könnten wir vielleicht zum
ersten mal verkaufen was es bedeutet
dass wir uns homo sapiens sapiens nennen
wörtlich die art die weiß dass sie weiß
dass sie weiß die art die ein
bewusstsein hat und die weiß dass sie
ein bewusstsein das tief greifend wir
nennen uns seit über 100 jahren so aber
ich glaube jetzt haben wir wirklich das
potenzial das auch zu verinnerlichen und
in dieser epoche eine art neue
renaissance hervorzubringen die all den
schaden und den terror wirklich
vermindern könnte der in verschiedenen
ländern und gesellschaften andauert und
enormes leiden und wahnsinn hervorbringt
uns darüber unterhalten wohin dieser weg
besteht der achtsamkeit dann ist ihr
programm des intel tagen hat ja
eigentlich wie drei elemente ist gibt
den body scan indem man den körper
achtsam beobachtet es gibt
unterschiedliche einfache yoga übungen
und die meditation und in all dem was
man tut ist ganz wesentlich nicht zu
urteilen und interessant ist ja wenn man
sich darauf einlässt ich hab selber auch
seinen kurs gemacht und um das sei für
mich selber auszuprobieren ist dass man
beispielsweise ich sagen soll
nicht ich bin traurig
sondern da ist trauer oder nicht mein
fuß ist kalt sondern da ist kälte in
meinem fuß und ein bisschen fühlt sich
das so an als würde man sich dauernd von
sich selber distanzieren und noch mal
habe ich mich gefragt ist das wirklich
gesunden so wie sie es darstellen ist es
überhaupt nicht gesund aber es geht
nicht um entkoppelung sondern um nicht
binden
ich weiß nicht wie man das auf deutsch
übersetzt aber es gibt einen großen
unterschied zwischen entkoppelung die
zur trennung führt und nicht bindung was
klarsicht bedeutet und dass sie ihre
ganzen erfahrungen zur verfügung haben
und ihr verhältnis zur erfahrung nach
innen wie nach außen
es ist also nichts und rennen in
gewissem sinne ist es eine riesige
umarmung der gegenwart von dingen body
scan ist eine tür zur meditativen
erfahrungen achtsamkeit yoga ist eine
weitere tür wie auch sitz meditation g
meditation oder meditation beimessen
man könnte sagen als erste annäherung
dass es verschiedene türen gibt die in
den gleichen raum führen
es sind alles formen der achtsamkeit und
der klassischen meditation und wie ich
eingangs schon gesagt habe die wirklich
zentrale form von meditation ist die art
wie sie ihr leben von moment zu moment
leben sogar wenn wir miteinander
sprechen
sie schauen mich an ich schaue sie an
man nimmt das irgendwie war natürlich
überlegen sie sich gerade die nächste
frage hören mir aber auch zu was ich
jetzt sage wenn wir uns in diesem
bewusstsein befinden
das ist 18 wenn sie nicht achtsam sind
verlieren sie den faden und wir könnten
auch aneinander vorbeireden nicht
aufeinander hören nicht richtig
aufeinander reagieren muss mir überlegen
die ich jetzt weitermachen
bei diesem bodies kann also dieser übung
in der man sich hinlegt und versucht den
fuß ganz bewusst zu spielen das knie und
den ganzen körper weiß es mir zum
beispiel mal passiert dass ich
eingeschlafen
und dann dachte ich zuerst das ist doch
wunderbar ich bin keine besonders gute
schläferin dann dachte ich das doch
prima wenn ich schon mal schlafen kann
kann ich mich entspannen aber darin
besteht nicht das ziel dieser meditation
uns alle wach bleiben aber viele leute
die zu mb s r therapie in die
stressabbau klinik kommen haben
schlafstörungen
das ist das erste was passiert wenn sie
stress oder emotionale schmerzen haben
chronische körperliche schmerzen was
immer meist mache ich deshalb mit den
patienten in der klinik energie ich sage
es ist in ordnung wenn hier die body
scan geführte meditation abends fürs
einschlafen nutzt so lange ihr sie zu
anderen zeitpunkten tagsüber anwendet um
wach zu wehren
die wirkliche herausforderung ist zu
lernen wie wir erwachen können nicht
bloß einzuschlafen
aber sie haben recht wir haben alle
großen schlafmangel deshalb ist es
wichtig eine art tiefe entspannung zu
entwickeln
die beste entspannung ist wenn sie in
einen wachzustand eintauchen ohne agenda
die menschen die vor
sie erwähnten zuvor dass sie nicht
bewerten
jeder der das versucht wird bald
entdecken dass es praktisch unmöglich
ist nicht zu bewerten
wir haben zu allem eine idee oder eine
meinung wir mögen dies haben das nicht
gern nicht bewerten heißt nicht dass sie
keine meinung haben sondern dass sie
sich bewusst sind wie werten sie in die
regel sind und dass dann nicht zu werten
wir versuchen also die gewohnheit des
viertels zu suspendieren bis mögen's und
nicht mögen und eine art freiraum der
gelassenheit zu schaffen
ein emotionales gleichgewicht klarheit
aber sie versuchen nicht dieses gefühl
hervorzubringen
sie entdecken dass diese qualitäts des
seins ein teil von ihnen ist alles was
sie tun müssen ist gewissermaßen all die
verbindungen zu kappen die uns in
unserem denken und in unseren
emotionalen reaktionen gefangen halten
das ist nicht entkoppelung sondern es
ist nicht bindung
wir werden einfach nicht so schnell
davon erwischt und wenn dann bemerkt
wir es und bringen uns selber zurück das
wird so gewonnen
es ist wie gewicht ihr geist geht los
sie bringen ihn zurück ihr geht sie
bringen ihn zurück das geht noch hilft
ihnen den muskel zu vergrößern aber wenn
sie über achtsamkeit als eine art muskel
sprechen so dass der geist geht sie
bringen ihn zurück geht los sie bringen
ihn zurück wird das an einem punkt
wirklich spannend sie wollen ihn nicht
zurückholen
trotzdem tun sie es was ist wenn ihr
muskel anfängt zu arbeiten
trotzdem vorhandenen widerstandes sie
haben wohin erwähnt viele in einer
stress behandlungs klinik machen jetzt
diese mein sohn es praxis oder man hat
vielleicht chronische schmerzen oder
schlafprobleme und versucht solch eine
technik zu implementieren im eigenen
leben damit es einem besser geht
ihnen geht es ja schon gut was ist für
sie das ziel des achtsamen lebens oder
wenn sie sagen ich kann einfach gar
nicht mehr anders leben wenn sie einmal
davon gekostet haben
die frage ist wollen sie schlafwandeln
durchs leben gehen oder es wach
wahrnehmen wollen sie für ihre kinder
präsent sein oder einfach an sie denken
als wären sie ein fälliger fantasie
stadt dass sie wirklich für sie da sind
die oder für ihre enkel für die natur
und für was auch immer sie können vom
automatismus unseres lebens derart
eingeholt werden dass wir wie sie vorher
gesagt haben wir gehen durch die
gegenwart und hoffen später einmal
bessere momente zu erleben wenn sie das
ein leben lang tun könnten sie das
wichtigste in ihrem leben verpassen
wer will dass ich habe gesehen sie haben
dort ein buch ist in den usa berühmt für
sein zitat darf ich ihn zitieren
vermutlich wissen ihre zuschauer das
trio in den 1800 30er jahren in concord
massachusetts lebt
kurorten pan fast zwei jahre lang
verbrachte er an einem see dem orden
pont und lebte dort so einfach wie
möglich
er sagte dazu ich ging in den wald denn
ich wollte bewusst leben und nur den
wesentlichsten dingen des lebens
gegenüberstehen ich wollte herausfinden
ob sie mich nicht etwas lehren könnten
um später im anblick des todes nicht
erkennen zu müssen dass ich gar nicht
gelebt hatte das ist sehr einfach das
leben zu verpassen weil wir dermaßen in
unseren köpfen gefangen sind auf
englisch gibt es einen ausdruck in
gedanken verloren
wir verlieren uns derart in gedanken
dass wir wirklich verloren sind
und wenn sie das über tage wochen jahre
tun besteht die gefahr dass sie die
wichtigsten seiten ihres lebens verpasst
ich habe das buch mitgenommen weil ich
ja ganz oft zitieren in ihrem buch im
alltag ruhe finden spielt es eine große
rolle und ist ja heute ein bisschen
dieses buch in der schweiz zumindest die
bibel der aussteiger sehr viele menschen
die sich vielleicht auch gegen die
gegenwärtige zivilisation sträuben die
sich etwas anderes wünschen lesen dieses
buch ein sehr berührendes buch ich habe
mich gefragt dieser frau der kante jahr
die menschen es bewegung nicht erkannte
diese art der meditation nicht sondern
er hat sich fallen hingegeben der natur
dem wechsel der jahreszeiten dem leben
mit dem wasser er ist auch immer früh
aufgestanden wie sie es auch empfehlen
in ihrem buch aber er hat nicht diesen
weg beschritten den sie beschreiben
dennoch hatte ähnliche erfahrungen
gemacht deswegen meine frage gibt es
unterschiedliche wege an dieses ziel zu
gelangen
es gibt viele verschiedene wege genau
wie auf den mount everest
es gibt verschiedene routen um auf den
mount everest zu gelangen sind
schwieriger als andere aber die armen
könnte sagen es gibt unendlich viele
wege um einen bestimmten punkt zu
erreichen
castro anbelangt
sie sagten er spreche nicht über
achtsamkeit das ganze wollten ist aber
würde ich sagen eine einzige schwärmerei
über 18
ihr verstand den moment die gegenwart
und der verstand die natur gewissermaßen
als lehrerin
er sagt er sei den ganzen tag unter die
tür gesessen und habe nichts getan so
das leder dem sah dachte was für ein
fauler und er tut nichts los dort habe
er schaute wie sich die sonne am himmel
bewegte mit der schatten wanderte er
hörte dem gesang der vögel zu er war in
verbindung mit al
manchmal stand er bis zur nase im teich
und beobachtete wie insekten auf der
wasseroberfläche
er praktizierte achtsamkeit ohne den
ausdruck zu benutzen
die antwort auf ihre frage ist also ja
es gibt unendlich viele möglichkeiten
achtsamkeit gekonnt zu pflegen
aber es hilft einige anleitungen zu
haben denn es gibt noch mehr
möglichkeiten es ungeschickt zu tun und
ihren sinn falsch zu verstehen
viele manager die beginn gegen waren zu
joggen wie verrückt um den marathon zu
rennen und die würden sagen das ist
meine art der mainzer mäßig gehe täglich
joggen ja und finde daran ändern ist
eine wunderbare meditation aber würden
sie sagen das ist sozusagen gleich gut
meint von es praktizieren wie sie
vorschlagen oder täglich joggen ging nur
wenn diese leute nicht sitzend
meditieren wollen weil es langweilt oder
sie es nicht mögen und ihren körper
bewegen wollen
begeistert hat kein problem damit dass
der körper rennt die frage ist was ist
ihre haltung gegenüber dem was sie
erleben
darin geht es bei der achtsamkeit um die
beziehung zur welt
es geht um ihr verhältnis zu dem was sie
erleben gemüse schneiden für das
abendessen kann eine achtsame erfahrung
sein
abwaschen einen marathon rennen ist
bestimmt eine achtsame erfahrung
frühere liebe machen ist eine achtsame
erfahrung ihren kindern gute nacht sagen
sie am morgen auf wenn es hängt einzig
davon ab wie groß ihre bereitschaft ist
präsent zu sein ohne ein programm oder
wie präsent sie sind mit einem programm
aber erkennen was für ein strenges
programm sie haben und darin nicht
gefangen seien die quellen der mine
schulessen ja ein stück weit auch der
buddhismus sie haben selber auch gesagt
dass sie in verschiedenen klöstern waren
und auch da meditation gelernt haben
selber bezeichnete sich aber nicht aus
buddhist haben sie selber überhaupt
keinen bezug zur religiosität stimmt ich
bezeichne mich nicht als buddhist
ich verstehe mich selber als glühenden
studenten die buddhistische meditation
weil die beste beschreibung von
achtsamkeit aus der buddhistischen
tradition stand achtsamkeit wird oft als
das herz der buddhistischen meditation
bezeichnet dazu müssen sie wissen dass
das wort für herz in allen asiatischen
sprachen das gleiche ist wie jenes für
geist
wenn sie also das englische meint von es
nicht gleichzeitig als herzlichkeit
auffassen verstehen sie nicht wirklich
worum es geht
das deutsche achtsamkeit übrigens hat
dieser bedeutung überhaupt nicht
es gibt also übersetzungsprobleme damit
man das auch wirklich versteht hingegen
glaube ich nicht dass es irgendein
problem gibt in bezug auf klassische
religiöse zugehörigkeit traditionelle
religion beinhaltet auch die eine oder
andere art achtsamkeit sie haben nur
unterschiedliche bezeichnungen
es geht nicht darum wie man achtsamkeit
in bezug auf religion definiert sondern
wie sie sie selber mit den grundlegenden
lehren
des glaubens in übereinstimmung sind
manche leute glauben an eine höhere
macht andere an die natur an die
schönheit das universum oder wie immer
sie es nennen
menschen sind aber sehr interessante
kreaturen
wir sind so klein in einem so großen wir
sind so empfindungsfähigkeit sie haben
ein bewusstsein
dann gibt es dieses gigantische
geheimnis und die frage nach dem sinn
was ist der sinn des ganzen
wir leben während ein paar kurzen
augenblicken die wir lebensdauer nennen
wie stellen wir uns dazu sie können eine
tief sakrale erfahrung mit dem heiligen
erleben auf einem weg der von außen
säkular erscheint das biete tiefen sinn
egal wie sie zur religion stehen
das wort religion stammt vom
lateinischen religio was zusammenbinden
bedeutet das heißt gewissermaßen die
punkte miteinander verbinden die uns
erlauben unsere kleinheit und unsere
ungeheure größe zu verstehen unsere
beziehung zum gesamten universum und die
beziehung zu unserem daheim zu unserem
heimatplaneten zu unseren kindern eltern
usw
es bietet tiefen sinn ohne zwingend
verbunden zu sein mit einem katechismus
hat philosophie oder einem glauben den
sie benennen müssen ich finde
interessant dass ganz viel von dem was
sie sagen nicht eigentlich erinnert an
die lehre der story der
philosophenschule in der antike denken
die amerikaner marc aurel epiktet die
ähnliche dinge eigentlich gesagt haben
die beispielsweise die seelenruhe sich
nicht binden nicht urteilen möglichst
ausgeglichen leben aber auch dieses
gefühl von ein teil seines großen ganzes
eines kosmos trotzdem hatte ich den
eindruck in dieser ganzen literatur ich
gelesen habe
es wird eigentlich nie auf die store
bezug genommen sondern stets auf den
buddhismus spricht dass tatsächlich
überhaupt keine rolle in der ganzen
diskussion
wissen sie da komme ich in
schwierigkeiten da ich kein philosophin
sind mir die historiker nicht wirklich
geläufig dix im englischen mainz
tourismus all das was sie erwähnt haben
aber es beinhaltet auch eine art von
strenge von zurückhaltung
ich ertrage schmerz ich ertrage was ich
nicht mag
das hat mit achtsamkeit nichts zu tun
ich kann also ihre frage nicht
beantworten inwiefern die wurzeln der
achtsamkeit in die historischen
tradition liegen kann
ich sage dass es gibt leute die sagen
dass die griechen genauer alexander der
große
nach indien gelangen bis zum indus fluss
sie kamen mit dem frühen buddhismus in
berührung der bereits seit 200 jahren
bekannt waren folglich ist es möglich
dass spuren davon die westliche welt
viel früher erreicht haben als allgemein
angenommen
ich glaube ich wenn sie sogar
zurückgehen zu den sammlern und jägern
als wir in prähistorischer zeit alles
sammelten und jagten aus sicht der
evolution wäre achtsamkeit eine hoch
selektiver eigenschaft wenn sie sich
nämlich im wald zu unachtsam verhalten
werden sie gefressen
vielleicht bevor sie kinder haben noch
einmal zurückgehen zu diesem boom zu
diesem enormen erfolg dieser bewegung
dann gibt es ja doch auch kritische
stimmen es gibt leute die diskutieren
unter dem titel mag meint von es die die
ganze kritik und sagen der grund warum
so viele leute zuflucht suchen in
solchen kursen ist unsere endlos
gestresste gesellschaft und ist auch
eine form von ich weiß nicht
kapitalisierten wirtschaftssystem dass
die leute unter druck setzt die müssen
immer mehr arbeiten haben vielleicht
immer weniger rechte es ist die ganze
stress gesellschaft die müde wird und
eigentlich müssten wir doch ansätzen bei
einer veränderung der gesellschaft und
nicht bei einer anpassung von uns selber
ihrer die uns auf diese kritik
ich bin vollkommen einverstanden
es ist ganz einfach immer wenn sich
etwas viral verliert oder sehr populär
wird wird es sofort stark vereinfacht
und soweit verzerrt ist es nicht mehr
erkennbar ist eine der tiefsten
schönsten und ethischen lehrern die die
menschen je hervor gebracht
eine tragödie wenn die kapitalistische
gerne als materialistische perspektive
darauf diese zerstören würde
bevor sie wirklich erblühen konnte
krankheit hat eine ethische basis es
geht darum wohlbefinden zu optimieren
und leid zu minimieren indem es ihn beim
hippokratischen eid ist das erste keinen
schaden anzurichten wie können sie
überhaupt wissen ob sie schaden
anrichten ohne achtsamkeit mit aussagen
wie es wird vom militär genutzt
es wird von unternehmen genutzt dass die
unternehmen das ausnützen und all das
das ist in gewissem sinn das risiko und
der preis des erfolgs
sie könne nicht erfolgreich sein ohne
dass alle es haben wollen
sein werden dass viele leute versuchen
ist für sich zu nutzen den eigenen
bedürfnissen anzupassen aber achtsamkeit
ist so mächtig dass ich davon überzeugt
bin dass es schließlich ein gutes ende
haben die leute langweilen sich sehr
schnell wenn sie achtsamkeit nicht
tiefgründig erfahren und was die
transformation der gesellschaft
anbelangt vor drei oder vier monaten hat
das parlament in großbritannien einen
parteiübergreifenden bericht
herausgegeben mit dem titel mind von
nation uk
darin werden viel mehr mittel und
programme für achtsamkeit verlangt in
vier bereichen der britischen
gesellschaft bildung gesundheitswesen
strafrecht und technologie entwickelt so
etwas hat es auf diesem planeten bisher
noch nie gegeben dass ein
regierungsgremium einen report heraus
gegeben hat um die bedeutung von 8
nachdruck zu verleihen sei es im norden
so mein fuß dennoch ist es so im film
die neue achtsamkeit der gerade vorhin
gezeigt wurde und den man auch online
noch sehen kann
da sagt ein manager von sap eine firma
in der mein schönes kurse umsonst
angeboten werden über mittag für die
mitarbeitenden sagt selbstverständlich
machen wir das eigentlich aus dem grund
der effizienzsteigerung für unsere firma
man hat also so ein bisschen den
eindruck eines trojanischen pferdes das
eingebracht wird in firmen sollte und
und sap es ja nicht alleine also fort
monsanto walt disney google alles firmen
die es solche kurse mainz kurse anbieten
schmerzt sie das auch oder sagen sie
weiterhin einfach das ist sozusagen die
kehrseite des erfolges
ich bin glaube ich einfach noch nicht
ganz sicher dass das tatsächlich seinen
weg dann finden wir das müsste ja
schlussendlich auch das management
verändern
ich bin dankbar dass sie in diesem punkt
nachhaken ins in gewisser weise ist es
für mich schmerzt
was speziell diese sap sache betrifft
ehrlich gesagt ist das noch nicht zu mir
durchgedrungen
da ist ja ein schweizer fernsehprogramm
ich kenne einige der leute die bei
google achtsamkeit unterrichten
fantastisch ich kenne leute die bei
twitter meint wenn es unterrichten und
in einigen weiteren firmen im silicon
valley und bei ford schauen sie wenn sie
sich mit dem kapitalismus einlassen was
wir aus meiner sicht tun
dann lassen wir uns auf die
kampfsportart aikido ein achtsames
aikido die kapitalisten glauben
vielleicht sie würden achtsamkeit nutzen
damit die belegschaft schneller arbeitet
oder härter für weniger geld effizienter
und weniger gestresst ist
aber sie verstehen das machtpotenzial
der achtsamkeit
die realität ihrer organisationen zu
verändern nicht wirklich ich bin ja
nicht blauäugig optimistisch habe aber
doch das gefühl dass hier ein möglicher
gesundungsprozess im gang ist so dass
sogar wenn gewisse leute achtsamkeit
ausnützen oder sie für ihre eigenen
zwecke verwenden alles in allem ist die
prognose zum heutigen zeitpunkt eher
positiv als negativ
sie mögen sagen weshalb gehen sie nach
davos weshalb gehen sie ans world
economic forum und sprechen zu den herrn
der welt und unterrichten diese
meditieren die antwort ist aus dem
gleichen grund die pflanzensamen und sie
wissen nicht wo diese wurzeln fassen wir
aber aus einer buddhistischen
perspektive kann man sagen alle menschen
sind in ihrer ersten natur buddhisten in
einem gewissen sinn sind sie bereits
erleuchtet was immer das heißt wir
versuchen nun dies als eine art ersten
anstoß für veränderung und heilung zu
kultivieren
das könnte sogar die veränderung des
kapitalismus einschließen
dieser dürfte die nächsten 2 300 jahre
nicht überleben
vielleicht nicht einmal die nächsten 50
jahren angesichts all dessen was sich in
der technologie tut inklusive
energieverbrauch meditieren sie mit dem
manager nur in ihren kursen oder
besprechen sie mit denen auch dinge und
kritisieren praktizieren wir miteinander
denn wenn wir nur darüber reden ist es
bloßes gerede los philosophie
es ist nur konzeptionell die praxis ist
nicht nur konzeptionell es ist das
entwickeln von bewusstsein das
bewusstsein muss man nicht erlangen weil
es teil von ihnen ist aber wir
trainieren die muskeln nicht also wissen
wir oft nicht wie wir dahin kommen
dazu kommt das ganze thema der eigenen
interesse
wenn sie den gewinn für sich selber
maximieren wollen und dies im rahmen von
achtsamkeit tun
erkennen sie möglicherweise dass sie
diese selbst sucht in richtung
unzufriedenheit führt und mehr schaden
bewirkt als gutes bringen
jetzt da wir genügend wissen über die
globale erwärmung und was mit der umwelt
geschieht man könnte auch das eine form
von achtsamkeit wir wissen genug um zu
wissen dass menschliche aktivitäten die
menschliche industrie wenn sie so wollen
tatsächlich das leben auf diesem
planeten bedrohen wie wir darauf
reagieren wird zum maßstab für unsere
verborgene genetische intelligenz ich
glaube wir sehen menschen und nationen
sich gegen die ursachen erheben die zur
aufheizung des planeten führen
damit ihr nicht all die gletscher
verlieren an taktiker und alles andere
das ist genauso achtsamkeit wie
dazusitzen ein und aus zu
vielleicht nicht ganz so positiv in der
einschätzung dessen was sie wirklich zu
verändern bereits in gut mir gefällt
dass sie dagegen
sehen sie wir sprechen über die
umsetzbarkeit vor allen dingen aber von
einem bestimmten standpunkt wenn sie
glauben ich sei zu optimistisch hätte
ich ihnen 1970 gesagt dass meditation
und yoga eingang in die schulmedizin
finden würden ist zum punkt wo es im
denken der leute tatsächlich eine
revolution hervorbrachte bezüglich
mensch und krankheit speziell chronische
krankheiten gesundheit wohlbefinden
langlebigkeit usw
sie hätten gesagt dass ich nicht bei
sinnen sei hätte ich ihnen gesagt dass
die nationalen gesundheitsbehörden
wissenschaftliche forschung über
meditation und insbesondere achtsamkeit
mit beträgen von hunderttausenden und
millionen von dollars finanzieren würden
hätten sie gesagt sie sind verrückt
das alles ist in den letzten 36 jahre
wirklichkeit
es gibt keinen grund weshalb ich
möglichst realistisch staat möglichst
optimistisch sein sollte lassen sie mich
zurückkommen zum achtsamen leben zu
ihrem alltag zu dem was sie empfehlen es
geht ja eben nicht darum wie sie schon
gesagt haben in bezug auf die frage ob
sie im flugzeug schon meditiert haben
nur eine meditation zu machen und dann
wieder durchs leben zu rennen bis man am
abend wieder meditiert und es geht darum
diese achtsamkeit in den alltag zu
integrieren sie sagen man kann auch
zusammen duschen 18 abwaschen 18 die
schuhe binden achtsamer kind kinder
erziehen und so weiter ich frage mich
wie können sie schon cover ziehen so
erfolgreich sein wenn sie gleichzeitig
so achtsam leben weil das braucht ja
unglaublich viel sage ich jetzt mal
langsamkeit und was passiert mit dem
ehrgeiz weiterzukommen erfolgreich zu
sein und so weiter
sie wissen schon was schon am nächsten
zu fragen
nein das ist gesunder menschenverstand
jeder würde eine solche frage stellen
ich weiß nicht recht wie ich antworten
soll in meine erfahrung ist dass
menschen wirklich nach tiefstem
wohlbefinden und zufriedenheit suchen
deshalb sind hier so gierig deshalb
versuchen wir immer einen besseren platz
zu bekommen sagt ja du willst dich einen
besseren platz bekommen in deinem grab
denn du tot bist und kurz vorher wird
dir klar vielleicht habe ich alles
falsch was ich sage ist stirbt jetzt
bring es hinter dich dann ist der rest
seines lebens ein geschenk du kannst
deine kraft seinen ehrgeiz deine liebe
nutzen um deinen beitrag an die welt zu
optimieren
erste person die davon profitiert bist
du selber aber du wirst nicht die
einzige person sein die provinz
weil du gewissermaßen zum geschenk für
die welt wirst dann ist auch die arbeit
die du verrichtet sinnvoller
sie wird andere menschen begeistern wenn
ein reiter in einem unternehmen
achtsamkeit verkörpert inspiriert dass
weitere leute jeder in unternehmen ist
befeuert länger zu arbeiten
dabei muss der leiter sagen arbeitet
nicht länger arbeitet klüger ich will
dass er nach hause geht und euch um eure
kinder kümmert und nicht nur bei der
arbeit ein großer erfolg sein
wir brauchen nicht so viel mehr geld was
wir brauchen ist ein größeres
gleichgewicht der dinge kann natürlich
sind wir finanziell erfolgreich das ist
aber nicht das ultimative kennzeichen
von erfolg hat erfolg muss viele
dimensionen haben und wir müssen ein
unternehmen entwickeln dass seine
belegschaft wirklich wenn ihr aber
mitten im alltag sitzen die kennen das
alle wir sind an unserem schreibtisch
wie verlassen dass den tisch sagen wir
für eine stunde für eine sitzung wir
kommen zurück 20 neue e mails
wie gehen sie damit um das ist eine sehr
große herausforderung
eigentlich fragen sie was macht die
technologie mit dem aktuellen momente
sind von einer analogen in eine digitale
welt geraten
wir vom digitalen derart aufgesaugt
werden dass wir vergessen dass wir immer
noch analoge wesen niemand hat das e
mail problem gelöst
für mich ist e mail wie ein wasserfall
wie der strahl aus dem feuerwehrschlauch
und kann nicht auf alles antworten so
schlenker ich mich durch ich antworte
nicht auf e-mails meine nicht antwort
ist ein antwort ich antworte mit
achtsamkeit bewusst nicht oder ich nehme
mir zeit
ich beantworte keine e-mail auf meinem
telefon
checke ich e-mails auf meinem telefon
wenn ich bereit bin werde ich mich um
ein e mail kümmern
aber ich will nicht dass es mich davon
abhält auf meine gegenwart zu 8 wie gut
bin ich darin wahrscheinlich nichts
becker ist weil ich jeden mit dem ich in
e-mail-kontakt bin gern habe und eine
innige beziehung zu ihm habe ich meine
damit mehr die arbeit als die familie
es gibt also dieses blühender
achtsamkeit wie sie gesagt haben und ich
bin darin starker revier aber zuviel von
etwas gute ist nicht gut
auch hier geht es um das yoga des
gleichgewichts
jeder von uns muss seinen eigenen weg
finden wie er damit umgeht
für jeden von uns hat der tag nur 24
stunden
ob mit oder ohne google ob microsoft
vorhanden ist oder nicht ob mit e mail
oder sms wir müssen neue wege finden um
unsere menschlichkeit in einer analogen
form weiter untersucht sheryl törkel die
auswirkungen der technologie auf junge
menschen
einige der resultat ist absolut
schockierend es ist also äußerst wichtig
achtsamkeit zum fliegen bei der
kinderbetreuung in der erziehung auch
ein buch geschrieben gemeinsam mit ihrer
familie mein team wird das scheint ihn
irgendwie gelungen zu sein ihre drei
kinder sind groß geworden und mit dem
sohn gemeinsam geben sie sogar
meditationskurse mittlerweile ja das
stimmt
und meine beiden töchter sind yoga
lehrerinnen
ich weiß nicht wie ich das erklären kann
in einem gewissen sinn könnte es
ansteckend sein aber es kommt nicht von
mir sie haben mich nicht nach sie tue
weil sie es auf ihre eigene einmalige
arzt tun kann
ich versuche mich da so weit als möglich
auszuhalten etwas was ich auch durch ihr
leben zieht sie sind nicht gern eine
person mit autorität haben schon im
krankenhaus nie gern einen weißen kittel
getragen weil sie sich gerne auf die
ebene der patienten gegeben sollten ist
ein sehr interessanter begriff in der
deutschsprachigen welt meint autorität
viel gewicht hohes ansehen
aber auf englisch es der begriff
autorität mitautor und mit authentizität
verbunden
es geht nicht darum autorität
vorzutäuschen die tiefste autorität ist
in gewissem sinn der autor seines
eigenen lebens zu sein
das geht nur wenn sie achtsam sind sie
können das nur wenn sie wach sind
denn dann ist das was andere leute von
ihnen wahrnehmen oder ob sie projizieren
worin sie sich nicht verfangen sollten
das ist eine bestimmte art von
authentizität
die leute kommen und sagen sie sind so
ich dir so echt
ich bin das zeigt wenn jemand wirklich
präsent ist hat man das gern
der dalai lama wird auf tibetisch oft
kunden genannt
es konnten kunden bedeutet des präsents
wenn sie mit dem dalai lama zusammen
sind und sie den sehr sorgfältig
beobachten er ist nicht ganz hier jetzt
er schaut nicht auf seinem hof und lässt
sich von keinem gedanken ablenken
dieses kultivieren von aufnahmefähigkeit
in die gegenwart berührt andere menschen
weil wenn ich präsident bin und wir in
einer beziehung zueinander stehen
ist dieser anders wenn ich bereit bin
den raum mit wachheit und herzlichkeit
zu versehen und das spürt man
gewissermaßen ohne je ein wort zu sagen
erlaubt das anderen menschen
herauszufinden
ohne mich wurde der fall einer mutter
teresa zu kopieren oder irgendjemand
anderen der für sie anhält ist aber
herauszufinden wer sie sind tag gefreut
und sich dann nicht im glauben zu
verfangen dass sie sind wir sie zu sein
glauben ihr narrativ ich bin dies ich
bin das ich bin so deprimiert so traurig
so ängstlich dass dieses narrativ hier
ich sei sie sind so viel mehr als ihr
narrativ letztlich hat wer sie sind
vielleicht mehr mit wachheit bewusstsein
achtsamkeit herzlichkeit zu tun als mit
ihrer geschichte für mich
jetzt haben ja vorher darüber gesprochen
wie man sich verhält am schreibtisch
wenn diese vielen e mails kommen sie
haben ein stück weit eine antwort
gegeben
gleichzeitig möchte ich zurück fragen
viele von uns sind ja wie soll ich sagen
nicht so frei wie sie ihr leben zu
gestalten viele menschen sind gebunden
sie müssen vielleicht ihren
lebensunterhalt verdienen eine familie
ernähren
gleichzeitig denke ich auch immer es ist
ein bisschen eine ausrede zu sagen ich
habe keine zeit sondern das allermeiste
was wir tun in unserem leben ist
präferenzen zum ausdruck bringen möchte
ich lieber noch ins kino oder möchte ich
lieber ins yoga oder möchte ich lieber
mehr schlafen als eigentlich lauter
entscheidung die wir fällen können und
trotzdem denke ich hoffe dass ich so
unglaublich schwierig diese
entscheidungen so zu treffen dass ich am
ende damit zufrieden bin wenn ich auf
lange sicht auf mein leben blicken dann
hat auch das gefühl dass wesentliche
konnte kurz warum warum nehmen wir so
eine sehr tiefgründige fragen beantworte
ich glaube es ist einfach eine schlechte
gewohnheit alle anderen ist und urig es
auch aber wenn sie damit aufhören und
anfangen zu hinterfragen wie ich schon
gesagt habe jeder hat gleichermaßen 24
stunden
wie gehen wir damit um was den schlaf
angeht das essen die familie den ehrgeiz
und wie wir die arbeit machen
das müssen wir wirklich steuern jeder
muss seinen eigenen weg finden so dass
wir unser leben authentisch leben statt
irgendeine geschichte wie wir sein
sollten wenn sie das tun scheint der
stress viel kontrollierbar weil sie es
steuern können und zudem glauben wir
irgendwie dass wir alles im griff haben
aber wir haben praktisch nichts im griff
einen tag sind sie gesund und schon am
nächsten tag können sie eine diagnose
erhalten die ihr ganzes leben verändert
das erleben menschen tag für tag
am wichtigsten ist nicht so sehr was
jemandem wie der fährt sondern wie man
sich dazu stellt dann wird das leben
selber gewissermaßen zum lehrplan und
dieser lehrplan wird sie auf eine art
formen die sich als heilung beweist es
ist nicht immer freude
es ist nicht immer schön es ist nicht
einfach sooo wunderbar ich bin ein
bruder ist ein problem hat ist es ist
eher wie im cartoon zuerst einmal
geschieht nichts das ist es nicht mögen
was lässt sie glauben dass der nächste
moment besser sein wird
doch wenn sie diesen jetzigen moment
bewältigen ist die zukunft bereits
anders weil sie präsent waren sich auch
dem unangenehmen gestellt haben sogar
dingen mit denen sie am allerwenigsten
zu tun haben wollen wie eine
krebsdiagnose oder chronische schmerzen
sie können diese auf eine art annehmen
die wir wird dass sie sich verändern
die wissenschaft zeigt dass es im
nervensystem veränderungen gibt auf die
ebene der chromosomen und der telomere
und viel wichtiger auf die ebene des
herzens hilfreich ist auch er stelle ich
mir vor ist natürlich auch wenn die
person die man vielleicht am meisten
liebt mitmacht
in dieser ganzen haltung zum leben haben
sie eigentlich ihre frau dazu gebracht
auch zu meditieren oder haben sie sich
schon als meditierende kennen genannt
ich müsste 24 stunden am tag meditieren
um mit meiner frau mitzuhalten
die von natur aus achtsam ist ja und ich
will auch sagen in den fast 50 jahren in
denen ich nun formell mittelstation
praktiziert habe sowohl sitz meditation
die andere formel bin ich dazu gekommen
dies als liebesbeziehung zu verstehen
das ist nicht bloß eine weitere sache
die ich in meinen tag hinein zwingen
muss eine art zum achten und entspannt
sein
es ist eine liebesbeziehung mit dem
leben und die einzige zeit fürs leben
ist in diesem moment so in die ihn
verpassen haben wir in diesem moment
unser leben verpasst so vernarrt
so gesehen ist meditation ein radikaler
akt des verstands ein radikaler
aktienmärkte und ein radikaler aktie
vernunft ich brauche weder meine frau
noch jemand anderen die ihr mit mir
meditiert um davon zu profitieren
manchmal meditieren wir in der tat
zusammen manchmal gehen wir zusammen in
einen retreat allerdings sehr selten
aber aus der perspektive von wie ich
erwähnt habe moment zu moment wenn wir
zusammen essen zusammen nacht essen
kochen oder was auch immer wir zusammen
machen wenn wir füreinander präsent sind
ohne einander zu zwingen sich auf eine
bestimmte art zu verhalten damit ich
glücklicher bin das ist liebe und das
ist achtsamkeit von cover ziehen haben
wir jetzt ein achtsames gespräch geführt
ich glaube sie kennen die antwort schon
ich lege dem nichts weiteres hinzu
vielen herzlichen dank sehr achtsam ist
erkennt die realität setzt sich zusammen
aus vielen einzelnen momenten der
wahrnehmung ein bisschen wie eine
collage eine technik die aus der
kunstgeschichte nicht mehr wegzudenken
ist und die für die dadaisten vor 100
jahren eine prägende ausdrucksform da
heute abend um 23.20 zeigen wir ihnen
den film remix manifesto der die
geschichte der collage nacherzählt und
wäre es spielerisch markt dem empfehle
ich unser doc projekt data klicken sie
rein und lassen sie sich überraschen
jetzt aber vor allem einen schönen und
achtsamen sonntag
[Musik]